do you remember the b-movie that Brendan
said he made a small cameo in the tax
collector no well the trailer just
released and I tried really hard and I
could not find Brendan to save my life
I'm in the mask you'll see me three
times
[Music]
for Los Angeles right 25 my left
chopping the truck blocking my dog
[Music]
child actor
oh dude he is phenomenal I that was my
biggest takeaway from doing that movie
the three-second nap I had in that movie
just being on set for like three or four
days with Shia LaBeouf my god he is a
[ __ ] fantastic actor he's so goddamn
good you know here's what's instrument
that is that when we taught it I didn't
know when it was coming out but it's a
David Ayer's movie who did training day
he did fury he did Suicide Squad all
that but he in order to make that movie
one of the act that Bobby Soto's father
is connected to the Mexican cartel so
it's based off a true story but where
they shot it they shot in straight
ghettos of Los Angeles but nobody messed
with the with the sets were any of the
shoots because they had real like shot
collars and gang members for security it
was really cool it was really like scary
but cool that's pretty wild
yeah yeah man he's something else that
kid he's something the [ __ ] else oh dude
I'm he is such a [ __ ] talent it's
insane
you gotta love acting to get that into
it you know the way he does everything
he's a nice full for fury he thought it
would look more realistic if he got a
two three mood so he actually took a
tooth out to film fury for this movie
tax collector his character creeper has
the chest tattoo that says I forget what
they might say creeper he get out a real
tattoo across his chest that's his
creeper Jesus Christ well yeah I'm not
an actor he says he's as committed as
they as they get then also you look at
what he does to give back
[Music]
you know underprivileged kids it didn't
say if I'm not a good dude he's a great
dude if he came up really had no money
his dad was selling hot dogs I think at
the stadium stadium yeah he has a very
tough upbringing it but also you look at
think about Shia LaBeouf he did that
movie peanut butter Falcon which got so
much high praise then he did the other
one honey boy which was his life story
that he wrote and directed and now he
did this one as well with David Ayers
he's a beast man he's special special
guy man
Steven Spielberg said that Seema
Spielberg saw something that said this
kid is the future you put them in that
Indiana Jones I'll tell you what though
after being on that set and like seeing
that like the dramatic roles and he's
this gangster stuff like that I was like
oh this isn't for me I got to watch him
I have to watch him play this serious
role this scene out over and over like
it's the most dramatic scene in the
movie and he kept doing it over and over
I'm like things like Joaquin Phoenix
watching him go over and over like
that's like that's a masochistic process
you gotta kind of like yeah it's not
comfortable to be in that position no I
think if it was a it was like a movie of
like all our friends and it was funny
like we did for final kid 3d that would
be fun but to do like a serious role
movie like that you're shooting for
months that just I knew like you know
off the bat like oh that's not for me
that's this life isn't for me sitting in
a trailer
waiting till I go on switching outfits
doing make fan up stand up for me stand
up stand up stand yeah I stand up I'm a
cartel down there I haven't seen the
final we have no idea how much I'm in it
I get audition for a really fun series
that I've just almost finished called
the boys about superheroes that are bad
these guys are super heroes and they're
just they're just take advantage of
their power so you you are me I I
auditioned I would never do something
but I saw and I went this is a [ __ ]
good role oh did you get it do you know
I don't know yet it would be something I
would do
because I can kill it I can kill it play
just sort of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
of a superhero do you think you're gonna
start maybe doing some more on additions
me for stuff that you want to do now or
now I don't think so but I think the
truth is that I just want to stick to
stand up and podcasting unless it's like
your good rule or something maybe but
I've never liked acting because I don't
like the process it's a little bit like
skiing skiing is fun when you're on the
hill and you're going down there it's
getting all the gear and the cold and
all that the amount of it's just [ __ ]
you'd go through with that I just never
liked the process I hate to say it I
have to admit that to myself at 53 I
spent my whole life thing and trying to
be an actor and I realized that so much
of it was my if you are Shia LaBeouf
Bradley Cooper you would love acting
guys love it all those guys me I had
options I like to be funny
I like to expand that's when I feel the
best that's what I feel the most alive
thank god you're really getting this
stand-up you know you know if you go
down that road of act and imagination
and you're trained in it and you get to
53 years old and you realize man maybe I
don't want to do this a lot you guys are
stuck you know they're stuck and you
know people are not paying actors
because they don't have to you don't
want to do that wrong we'll just go over
here no prob you don't want to do it for
scale plus 10% that's all right you're
great but we have three other dudes or
maybe ten other guys we're all really
good
I was talking this time stagger about
this last night like thank God were able
to still do our podcast and stuff like
that because you know you
even with this Crona stuff it's maybe
you know really Megan Kron it's like
alright how much do I do want to do the
road until they figure stuff out stuff
like that but it's like thank God I have
that option to decide what I want to do
thanks to podcasting thanks to you bring
with me doing this [ __ ] how many
years ago the sign the [ __ ] ride it
to the wheel song crazy
alright yeah but that will be my acting
debut okay I might have a mask on you
will see me in the restaurant as well I
think let's they added me on the whole
thing but
laughs okay on MADtv sometimes you'd
have to be in four hours of makeup just
to be in the background
cuz you'd be wearing prosthetics you do
an elastic they paint rubber or [ __ ]
face pieces on there well how about how
about Jim Carrey to play The Grinch they
said he's been making up for 14 hours
sometimes you'd go crazy you don't have
to sit there yes I go crazy
it wasn't 14 hours but it was I promise
it was a long time it's more like five
hours like no no no as long as that
because he said he had to get some
training some mental training to get
through it yeah usually it's usually
it's four hours I've done I've done the
exactly that makeup so I can tell you
well you've done the grit yeah I've done
that kind of makeup I've had that kind
of crazy amount of makeup on so a lot of
times they say it's a face mask but
you're wearing you have a ball Payton
you have a wig there's a lot I've done I
just hold on spending two hours of the
morning getting in when I leave and get
out okay it'll take more than 48 hours
it'll take more than two hours though
I've been in makeup for as long as three
hours three hours I mean listen how much
do you get paid for the grinch shut your
[ __ ] mouth get in the mail there for
two hours I was going oh you know what I
meant 14 hours total come on you can go
crazy though cuz what happens is you're
you're in that mess and you can't really
eat or do anything you have to drink out
of a straw and you can't move so you're
you're old you're in that you're wearing
essentially glue and rubber on your face
for 16 hours and then you go home and it
takes an hour to get out then you go
home you wake up really early and you
start all over again it's a [ __ ]
it's claustrophobic I'm gonna tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]